- The African American Studies Department
at Yale's Endeavors Series.
This is like our colloquium
where we learn and wander together.
This being the second on an
anthropology of abolition,
also an anthropology of liberation,
is here with a tremendous
group of scholars
who I could not be more excited
to be you learning from.
The housekeeping is for those of you
who are not amongst the panel,
I will encourage you to
turn your cameras off.
The reason I'm encouraging
you to turn your cameras off
is because we are recording this
and we will eventually
be putting this up online
is the ideal.
And if you do not want to be online
or you do not out want
to sign the paperwork,
cameras off is deeply preferred.
The other bit is,
if you would go ahead and put
your questions in the chat,
keep your mics on mute.
And Aimee will,
during the Q and A be able to facilitate
those questions for you.
Please go ahead and put them in the chat,
populate them in there.
I have a feeling we will
have lots of question
for all the tremendous wisdom
we are about to receive.
So with that, in this spring of 2022,
it is my great pleasure to introduce
the trend setting, trail blazing,
pinnacle of the apotheosis of
anthropological excellence,
Aimee Cox, to introduce
the rest of this panel.
Thank you all so very much.
And again, welcome to African
American Studies Endeavors.
- Ah, Phil, thank you so much.
I knew you would coming hot.
So, even a few minutes late,
it's like Phil comes in hot.
So thank you so much for
starting us off so vibrantly,
I also wanna thank Vanessa Epps
who's our senior administrative assistant
in African American
Studies for all the work
that Vanessa did to organize
all the details around this
Endeavors Series.
So wonderful to see all of you here
and more people are still arriving
or at least to see you
in your Zoom squares,
but I'm not at all surprised
given who we are in
conversation with this morning
into this afternoon.
But first, I want to
start off by expressing
how profoundly fortifying,
even before we have
begun our conversation,
the anticipation of a
conversation with you,
Deb, Savannah and Christen is,
because I not only have
deep respect for your work
but I also care deeply about you.
And I do think that maybe
like two and a half years ago
I may have been a little hesitant
to express that sentiment
in an academic context,
to be completely honest,
but much has changed in the
past two years and a half.
And it has become clear to me at least
that operating as if care and connection
are outside of our intellectual concern
or irrelevant to our scholarship,
constitutes a persistent,
if subtle, type of violence.
And I would add care and
connection are essential
for how we think about
abolition and move towards it.
So this is a conversation that
we have been having already
in many ways across time,
phases in our careers,
several different institutions
and our own shifting
relationship to the academy,
our research and the
discipline of anthropology.
But this is now a conversation
that takes place in...
And I'm doing this "these times."
Over the past two and a half
years, almost three years,
we have heard the phrase "in
these times" more than ever,
the times that people are
referring to could range from
the ongoing global pandemic and
the lives taken in its wake,
global protests against anti-Blackness
and structural racism, threats
to an idealized democracy,
the disruption of identities
constructed on strict binaries
and scales of comparison,
and the realization that former
modes of supposed stability
through financial security,
social respectability
and the accumulation of
credentials are no longer viable.
I will pause here, but the
list could go on as you know,
but these are the times we ourselves in,
which also means,
these are the times the
discipline of anthropology
and the concept, an act of
abolition move within and around.
The academic iteration of anthropology
is also currently confronting a long...
Let me be clear, a long history
of sexual violence that is just one...
Let me be clear,
just one branch on the
deeply rooted tree of power
held by singular gatekeepers
who not only violate
bodies and boundaries,
but determine who gets
hired, mentored, awarded,
and which scholarship is
legitimized as knowledge.
So, when I shared the idea
for today's conversation
with a close friend of mine
who happens to be a literary scholar,
their response was, and I quote,
"You mean to say the
abolition of anthropology,
"not an anthropology of abolition, right?
"Because the abolition of
anthropology is the only way
"those two words can be
reconciled in the same breath."
And my response was,
who said, we should be
seeking reconciliation.
I don't know,
can anthropology serve
the ideals of abolition?
And then what about
that slash in the title,
the slash in the title between
abolition and liberation,
are they truly an and/or,
or have I too readily
assumed a direct link?
Can we get specific about our terms
so that they inspire
action and accountability,
and not just the ongoing loop
of our perpetual theorizing?
I don't have easy answers,
I doubt any of us do,
but we do have the gift of
three courageous thinkers
to wade in these choppy waters with us.
So, this is how we will proceed today.
I'll introduce our three speakers
and then each will offer opening remarks,
starting with Dr. Shange.
Can I use your first names, do you mind?
(laughs) Starting with Savannah,
moving to Christen and then moving to Deb.
I'll moderate the conversation
for about 20 to 25 minutes
before opening up to your
questions and comments
so that we can have a full
dialogue in this space.
So, Savannah Shange,
who gets a big hand clap for joining us
at 5:30 in the morning.
Should I reveal where you are,
so we don't feel so
sorry for you (laughs)?
So, Savannah is an Assistant
Professor of Anthropology
at UC Santa Cruz,
and also serves as principal faculty
in Critical Race and Ethnic Studies.
She earned a PhD in Africana studies
in education from the
University of Pennsylvania.
"MAT," is that a master's in education,
masters from Tufts University
and a BFA in experimental theater
from Tisch School Of The Arts at NYU.
Her first brilliant book,
"Progressive Dystopia:
Abolition, AntiBlackness,
and Schooling in San Francisco,"
published by Duke in 2019,
is an ethnography of
the afterlife of slavery
as lived in the Bay Area.
And also, and Savannah,
I hope you've added this to your bio.
It's also the winner of the
prestigious Bateson Book Prize,
that's awarded through the society
for cultural anthropology.
Savannah, we're so happy to have you here.
We give you a virtual hand clap.
Christen A. Smith,
is Associate Professor of Anthropology
and African and African diaspora studies
and director of the Center
for Women's and Gender Studies
at the University of Texas at Austin.
Her work focuses on the
immediate and long term impact
of policing on Black
communities in the Americas,
particularly on Black women.
She's the author of
over 20 peer reviewed articles and essays,
multiple public commentaries
and a brilliant book,
"Afro-Paradise:
Blackness, Violence, and
Performance in Brazil"
published in 2016,
which won an honorable mentioned
for the Errol Hill Award in 2017.
Christen is also currently
completing three books.
Is that true, Christen?
Christen is in the middle of
three brilliant book projects.
Which I hope you'll talk about
as we get into our conversation.
Deb A. Thomas,
Deborah A. Thomas is the
R. Jean Brownlee Professor
of Anthropology
and Director of the Center
for Experimental Ethnography
at the University of Pennsylvania.
She's the author of
"Political Life in the
Wake of the Plantation,"
"Exceptional Violence"
and "Modern Blackness."
Thomas co-directed the
documentary films "Bad Friday"
and "Four Days in May."
And she is the co-curator
of a multimedia installation titled
"Bearing Witness: Four
Days in West Kingston."
Prior to her life in the academy,
she was a beautiful...
Not prior to, still a dancer,
but she was a professional dancer
with the New York based Urban Bush Women.
Can we give a virtual hand clap
to our esteemed panelists today?
So, I'm gonna open up,
with you all opening up
and you're opening remarks.
And I want you to open up
in whatever way feels right to you.
But if this is a helpful prompt,
I thought we might interrogate
some of the assumptions
that I might be making in
the terms that I'm using.
So, abolition is a word
that many of us use now,
I would say in past, maybe five years,
it's become more mainstreamed,
associated with policing
in the carceral state more specifically,
but then now it has this traffic
and people are attaching it
in the way that we do it in the academy.
And there's this assumption
that we're all using it
or understand how we're using it.
And I'm wondering how you
enter this conversation
and your relationship to
the concept of abolition.
But then I thought,
am I also making an assumption
about anthropology, right?
Do you, in this moment, consider
yourself an anthropologist?
What is your relationship to the field?
Because your work is housed
in an anthropology department
and read by anthropologist or not,
how do you assess your relationship
to the discipline of anthropology?
And this could be within
and outside of the academy
and then how do we reconcile or not,
referring to that question from my friend,
the concept of abolition
and what we understand to be
the practice of anthropology?
Or you can just ignore that
and just whatever you wanna say
to open up is fine.
But we'll start with Savannah.
Savannah, I'm gonna turn it over to you.
- Thank you so much
for that really beautiful
introduction, Aimee.
And it's so wonderful to
be here with so many folks
who have literally shaped
my path to this moment.
So, it's wonderful to be here with you,
Christen and Deb too.
So yes, I feel like this past
year and a half has really,
I think highlighted for
me the need to be clear
about what it means when we say abolition,
because I feel like 10 years ago,
I feel like people who said it,
I was on the same page with them.
And now, we're in a different moment.
And actually just recently I
finished working on a piece,
trying to work through this very concern.
So I think I'll share
maybe a couple pages of it
and then talk about how it
brings me back to this moment.
And so it starts,
do you remember maybe some
folks here, June and July, 2020
when in addition to our communities,
rising up in the streets,
our colleagues who were not in the streets
were rising up in our emails
to ask us to appear every six minutes.
You remember that, right?
And so what started as a series of,
we had some really
generative conversations,
but then you're on the third
talk in the sixth week,
you start being kind of a
blank thought vending machine,
It's a PEZ dispenser
for bites of abolition.
And I realize, I'm just gonna say,
I put myself in that position
by putting abolition in
a subtitle of my book,
not knowing this is where I
was going to be in this moment.
And so, I've been thinking
about what it means to use
the kind of (indistinct) logics
that come out of search
engines like Google, right?
In the ways we even
literally title our work.
Because then the same
engines of surveillance
and digital capture then serve
to lubricate certain kinds of pathways
to finding certain kinds of works
as an entryway to
something like abolition,
when there's other places,
namely the streets that you live on
and the places that we work,
that are better entrance points,
at least I think more earnest ones.
And so, I was asked in
one of these sessions,
how do you maintain faith in anthropology
while doing abolitionist work?
And this was a really earnest question
from a fantastic and super
engaged graduate student.
And I realized that I had...
The fact that this was the question,
really let me know how off path I was
because embedded in the logic
of a question like this,
and this was a good faith question.
This was not...
This is someone really trying to do
the best work they can imagine.
There's a twin assumption that,
1, anthropology and abolition
are reconcilable and then,
2, my spiritual investments
include a academic discipline.
That's wrong on both counts,
but it's really on me
for having set that up.
And so,
I think that as someone
who for better or worse
has hung my hat on abolitionists
anthropology as a phrase,
I think I set up both the
audience in these kind of spaces
and myself with a okie-doke,
because monographs are
meant to be consumable.
They're bite-able, they're citable,
and abolition is supposed to be ignitable.
These aren't the same kind of function.
And I think it's important to remember
that abolition is not a metaphor, right?
And that our notion of abolition,
it's essential that doesn't
get de-fanged and (indistinct)
within these kind of
self-evident boundaries
of a discipline or the academy.
And so, to maintain faith
in anthropology
while doing abolitionist work
implies a temporality in
which, like Aimee said,
the discipline is ongoing and abiding.
While abolition would
be a tactical modifier
of labor in the meantime.
The desire to deserve to
conserve the discipline
in the face of impossible demands,
harkens to what Ryan
Jobson that same year,
named the anthropological fix,
Whether it's technological,
status, (indistinct).
And Ryan reminds us
that rather than looking to the discipline
to bolster our faith,
quote, "The decisive action
require to resolve a crisis
"in anthropology on the contrary
will not being confined to the
halls of convention centers
or university departments."
And of course not to like
a Zoom webinar, right?
Because abolition is not a fix.
It's the reverse.
And unfixing in the sense
of disrupting both the locus
and the function of captivity.
Given the distance between
our discipline's liberal center of gravity
and the demands of abolition,
it becomes clear that the question
from this graduate student
had it all backwards, right?
Instead of wondering the reverse,
how do we maintain faith in abolition
while doing anthropological work?
And so I couldn't think
of this at the moment,
this is kind of...
I was thinking about this in response
to this really generative question.
And for me, the answer is clear.
Every empire falls
and this little settler dumpster fire
that we find ourselves
in, is no different.
The planet that we freight so much about
will be absolutely fine.
The earth will heal itself
and regenerate life,
time and time again,
over the next billion years.
The question is about,
whether humans will be
around to bear witness?
And so, any student of history
knows the structure of the United States
like any nation state is
also gonna change and morph
in one way or another in
the next few hundred years.
But most likely those
transformations will fortify
the fatal forces of white
supremacy and patriarchy.
The question is how we intend
to both shape and survive
those transformations, right?
So in 2021, 23,
will we see the North American
corporate military structure
grow even more powerful in
the ruins of neoliberalism?
Or will we see autonomous communities
accountable to indigenous lands
towards whole large swaths of land?
Will it be of both?
And so I think the last
piece I'll share here
is about where ethnographic practice
and anthropological ways
of knowing fit in here.
And I think that amidst all of the miras
that the person you were
talking about, Aimee was saying,
this has to go, right?
Amidst everything that
has to go into the bin,
let's think of it as a compost pile
that anthropology has to go into.
Which means it's gonna have to decompose
and something else could
potentially be fed from that.
And particularly there's parts
of the disciplinary toolkit
that are really useful for world making,
listening deeply, bearing witness,
challenging the
inevitability of the state,
building deep transnational
and cross diasphoric relations,
in particular as surveillance
and policing and imprisonment
become globalized as
techniques of oppression,
anthropology can help us
disrupt U.S. centrism,
while cultivating thicker solidarities
that function as political pathways.
And so for me abolition is about
attending to the break,
stretching open the cracks
in captivities infrastructure
and ethnographic practice is a technique
that can help us attend to
life as it is in this moment,
one that has the potential to attune us
to world making as it's
happening everywhere.
And so...
Aimee, do I have another minute.
- Please, go ahead.
- Okay.
So was anybody at one of the first
Critical Resistance
Conferences that's here,
feel free to say in the chat,
do y'all remember, there
was one at maybe...
I was at the one at Columbia,
but there's one before
that maybe at Riverside.
And so, at these initial CR
Conferences in like 97 and 99,
correct me on the years,
when folks said abolition,
it was understood as a
very direct reference
to destruction of the prison
industrial complex, right?
Policing wasn't even that central
to the table at that moment.
It was really specific about
the prison-industrial complex,
what some people would now
call mass incarceration,
but that's not the call,
the call is to end all incarceration,
not justify certain people's captivity
in order to free others.
And of course the theory
of prison abolition
was not born at that
conference or any conference
in the history of anti-carceral thought
goes back depending on
how you wanna map it from,
Du Bois, from...
There's lots of ways to think about it.
George James has a great
historiography of that,
but it wasn't until the 2020 uprisings
that the abolitionist proposition
appears to mainstream U.S. consciousness
with the (indistinct) demand, right.
"Defund the Police."
And there was so much hostility
and patronizing happening
in response to that,
that folks literally like Mariame Kaba
had to literally write a oped that said,
yes, we mean literally abolish the police.
And so in the meantime,
there's been this rebranding
and bad faith efforts
to co-opt abolition as anything but,
and I have plenty of examples
of that, that I won't share.
But for me, what I've
been thinking about is
what are the different modes of abolition.
So even among those who are
in the wheelhouse of okay,
ending captivity and all of
the things that could cause it,
there's still a lot of
generative diversity
within that frame.
And so I've been thinking about abolition
as five years of a moving
stick shift vehicle,
shout-out to everybody
who can drive manual.
using Chela Sandoval's theory
of differential consciousness
that works through a gear.
And so those gears would be,
we might think of as
abolition as rupture, right.
Which is changing the
conditions of captivity.
Rupturing the common sense
that produces captivity.
So someone like Mariame Kaba
and the Insight Collective.
Those are folks who are
moving in this world,
also thinking about
anthropologists that engage that...
I actually think of your work, Christen,
as really moving in that mode of abolition
in the sense that,
yes, you attend to
anti-Black state violence
in Brazil and the U.S.
But also to the sequela,
the trail behind that
spectacular event of violence
and the lives of mothers,
partners and children of the slain.
And so by tracing those
after lives of violence
that mirror this threat
and neglect and harm,
you make sure that we interrupt,
yes, this spectacular event,
but also the threads that come
before and after it, right?
You might think that there's
another mode of abolition
that's abolition as a revolution.
Direct confrontation with the state,
a tradition of abolition
that draws its power
directly from ongoing
revolutionary struggle
led by incarcerated people
and political prisoners.
So folks like, Joao Costa
Vargas or (indistinct) Britain,
Engage in this tradition,
even within anthropology.
And they're not doing
that work as anthropology,
they're doing that work
as anthropologists.
And so, and trying to
figure out how that happens.
You also might look at folks
who use abolition as healing.
Really doing that work of
accountability and transformation
and doing the work of
creating practical safety
in our communities
and transforming the impact
of interpersonal harm.
And so someone like Brendane Tynes,
who works on survivor organizing,
I think really live us up
that tradition of abolition
in our discipline.
The last two were thinking
about abolition as geography.
Building spaces of self-reliance.
And so, I'm looking to
someone like Ashante Reese
and her work around self-reliance
to help us sketch out what
might that practice look like
in the discipline.
And finally abolition as culture.
As the practice of finding one another
and building spaces between people,
because abolition is
something that only lives
in the space between people.
And so here, I'm thinking
about, Deb, your work,
not just the end product of the films,
of the film and the...
So thinking about "Bad Friday,"
thinking about "Bearing Witness,"
but also thinking about
the long form process
to produce those as
operating in that register.
Also like the podcast "Zora's Daughters,"
the Cite Black Women Collective.
This work of producing
abolition between us.
And then for me, I'll just take it home
with the folks that I learn
most about abolition from
is the Black Organizing Project,
which is an organization
that I'm a member of.
I'm an anthropologist who is
a member of the organization.
I'm not an anthropologist
of the organization.
I push in chairs, I tuck in...
I'm pushing chairs, I make phone calls,
I'm on the phone tree.
This image that you see
here is from a retreat
that some of the organizers put together.
This is the crew of folks
who have been holding the
George Floyd Resolution
for the elimination of
school police in Oakland,
which successfully passed in June, 2020.
The Oakland School Police
Department has been abolished.
The guns have been melted
down, the cars decommissioned.
They're off the payroll.
And in the past year and a half,
it's been this group of people
that have been helping to
create new job descriptions
for the security staff,
they have been creating new safety trees
for different kinds of incidents
at the elementary, middle
school and high school level.
Really doing this dreary week to week work
of producing abolition in real life.
And so, I brought them here
as my own guides in this work.
- Thank you so much, Savannah,
so much to think with.
I'm just thinking about the five...
I don't know if you
would call them tenants
or entry points or interventions
in the way that you think of abolition,
but each one of them gives
us so much to think about.
And what I love about that
is it doesn't begin and
end with an ultimate...
Rupture is not the
beginning and end, right?
Rupture is one node.
And so that, there's a way that we can see
the work that we're doing,
the steps towards a bigger rupture.
If we wanna call the
rupture, the revolution,
there's steps towards that.
And there's ways that we
can see that in our work
in the daily work that happens,
whether it's inside the
academy or outside of it,
so that we don't have to
constantly be operating
in these false binaries of
activists, non activists
in old school ways that
don't speak to the ways
that we can be attuned to the
possibility for transformation
and what might seem
like the smallest acts,
while still not relying
on those small acts
to do all of the work.
But there's a progression in
the way that we understand
what abolition means
or what it could mean.
So thank you so much for that.
Christen, I'm gonna turn it over to you.
- Thank you so much.
Before I get started,
I just wanna make sure I thank everybody.
So, I definitely wanna thank you, Aimee,
for pulling this all together.
It's beautiful to be in conversation.
And I know that we're not in person,
but there's something comforting
about seeing all of these
wonderful and amazing faces
that have inspired my work.
I'm gonna echo Savannah's words,
Savannah's work, your
work, Aimee, Deb's work
have really inspired the
work that I do as well.
And so I just feel like
I'm in community right now.
And I just wanna say, thank you.
And I also wanna say thank
you to Vanessa Epps as well
for helping us get all
organized prior to this moment.
And thank you to the Department
of African American Studies
and the Yale Endeavor Series
for allowing us to be in conversation.
So I wanna start just really briefly
because I'm not sure how much people know,
who I am or what my work is.
And so I just wanna start by saying,
I'm gonna talk about
the anthropology of
liberation and abolition.
And I definitely wanna get back
to some of the things Savannah said,
because Savannah, your interventions
about those five points,
I really appreciate them.
And they got me thinking
about some things.
So, I can't wait to
talk to you about them,
but my work has focused on thinking
about the terrorizing impact
of policing on Black people,
particularly in Brazil,
but across the Americas
for the past 20 years.
And so, when Savannah
mentioned the fact that
in summer of 2020,
when all of a sudden abolition
becomes this mainstream word,
for many of us who have
been doing this kind of work
around anti-Black policing
for quite some time,
that was a vertigo moment.
It felt really interesting
because it meant that the
hegemony was shifting.
It meant that the terms
that we have been using
for quite some time
had been pulled out from under us.
And so, I wanna just underscore that
because I think that that
was part of the thread
that Savannah was getting to.
But I think that,
one of the provocation
that's in this panel
is what do we do with the
terms that comfort us?
What do we do with the politics
that we have become familiar with
and where is it leading us,
and where do we go with that?
And so,
quickly, my work has been
on the gender dimensions
of anti-Black policing and
particularly the unique frequency
of Black women's
experiences with policing,
and what this frequency says
about space, about time,
about gender and anti-Black violence.
For me, my work,
and this is gonna sound different
to those of my colleagues
who are bonafide archeologists.
But I really think of my
work as archeological,
in that it entails excavating
the cemeteries of Black life
across the Americas,
through time and space in
order to map, mark and catalog
the artifacts of Black life
in the wake of anti-Blackness.
And I use the phrase in the wake
to follow Christina Sharpe's
brilliant theorizations
of the wake.
So for me, this archeological work
of tending to the dead and the living is
what Anthropologist
Faye Harrison has called
"decolonizing anthropology,"
or what Anthropologist
Keisha-Khan Perry has called
"an anthropology for liberation."
What is that?
Well, to paraphrase their
understandings of it,
it's an anthropological practice
that focuses on the possibility
of undoing the (stutters),
excuse me, the coloniality of anthropology
through the distortion.
And I use that word very specifically
through the distortion
of his normative practice
and the service of those
that has historically sought to catalog
in order to be colonized.
Or to follow Zora Neale Hurston,
seeking to upturn anthropologies legacy
as the deep practice of white
supremacies need to know.
And so, part of what I see embedded
in the title of this conversation today
is in actuality, a question, right?
Can we have an anthropology
for liberation?
Can we have an anthropology for abolition?
And what are the internal contradictions
that are inherent therein?
So for me, intending to
the dead and the living,
and I wanna underscore that my
work intending to the living
has necessarily been in
community with the dead,
because most of the times
when I'm doing my ethnographic
and anthropological work,
I'm working with those
who have been left behind
after their loved ones have
been killed by the police.
Which is a very grief based,
and tender practice.
I'll just say it that way.
And so one of the things that
I am constantly attentive to,
and this is something that
I also find inspiration
in Deb's work.
Particularly around
witnessing and thinking about
how do we have these conversations
in the aftermath of violence,
but how do we excavate our
stories without violating,
yet again, our graves?
After all,
grave robbing is a traditional
fundamental element
of the anthropological/archeological
process of excavation.
In conducting my research,
I constantly grapple with
this fraught tension,
rigorous qualitative research,
at least within the bounds
of traditional anthropology
seems to require that we as ethnographers
journey into the communities of the dead
to peel back the layers of
people's lives and sentiments
in order to discover the truths
of the past and the present.
Yet there is something
deeply unsettling to me
about this process that
pushes us to rethink
the meaning of liberation.
What does Black liberation look like
and what does it entail?
So, as somebody who spent
my entire career doing work
in collaboration with
Black movements in Brazil,
I have learned a lot from
them and from those movements.
And so I wanna situate
what I'm about to present
as learning from, as
opposed to studying on,
because I think that that's
also one of the themes
that comes through in this conversation.
What does it mean for us to engage
in collaborative processes
that are not based on extraction
or somehow based on
the continued processes
or the continued practice of genocide,
for lack of a better word?
But instead seek to learn from,
and be in community with folk
in order to find solutions
to our common experiences,
as people with targets on our backs,
I'll put it that way.
And so one of the things
that I've learned is that
if we are to possibly have an
anthropology for liberation,
whatever that looks like,
and I love the questions that
you put to the front, Aimee,
because I'm not convinced of anthropology.
I'm also not convinced
that anthropology and liberation
can be in conversation
with one another.
That is definitely not
something that I want to reify.
What I do want to do is to say,
if that is a possibility,
if there is something there,
what might it look like?
And for me to center Black
life and Black freedom
must necessarily upturn imperialism,
upturn heterosexism, upturn misogyny,
in addition to anti-Blackness.
And I put those things alongside that,
because I think despite our efforts,
we still engage in the
incessant practice of linearity
when it comes to understanding oppression,
meaning when we're talking
about anti-Blackness,
we tend to think about it
as separate from gender,
as separate from imperialism,
as separate from various
heterosexism and things like that.
And I think that that is still a frontier,
as familiar as that may sound.
And so, in thinking about that,
I have started to think about
the question or the practice,
the historical practice of Quilombo,
or (indistinct).
Which is the practice
in marronage in Brazil.
And Savannah, when you made
your comments about abolition
and abolition as territory making
and community building, et cetera,
I couldn't help but think
about the practice of quilombo
in conversation with that,
because despite the fact
that the word abolition
does not come up in the
conversations in Brazil
around quilombo, right?
We can think about these
things in conversation,
in diasporic conversation.
And specifically thinking
about the practice
of quilombo to follow,
(speaks foreign language),
which is this idea, not only
of building spaces of refuge,
but of building war encampment,
and the reason why I want
to bring out the idea
of war encampments
is because I think that
one of the things that may allow us
to think about an
anthropology for liberation
is to think about it as offensive,
as an offensive tactic,
not as a defensive tactic
and embedded within the notion of quilombo
is an inherent understanding
of the ecologies of violence
that we are up against.
It is an inherent understanding
that we must build spaces of refuge.
We must build spaces that
will proliferate Black life
and reproduce Black life,
but entailed in that
is defending ourselves
in some way, shape or form.
Whether that mean taking the high ground
and establishing ourselves
in the mountains,
or that mean setting up
autonomous economies,
or that mean somehow figuring out a way
to fight back against our oppressors.
And so,
I want to put that on the table,
because I think that
in order for us to think about
the possibilities of
anthropology and liberation,
there must be some sort of break
going back to something
that also Savanna said,
there must be some sort of break
with anthropology as we know it.
And that break,
has got to be defined clearly.
And so if we know anything about marronage
and we know anything about quilombo,
the practice of quilombo.
In many ways, these are
territories that are created
and autonomous spaces that are created
by people who escaped slavery.
Enslaved Africans who fled
the institution of slavery
to create autonomous societies,
and then fortify themselves
against the onslaught of violence
that was in opposition to Black freedom.
What we know is that quilombos
are never a outside of the colonial space.
Quilombos are never located in an area
that is beyond the zone of oppression.
And so I think for me,
that's a helpful place for us to think
about what an anthropology of
liberation might look like.
Because to think that
we are gonna get out of,
the colonial zone of
oppression of anthropology
by practicing anthropology,
is not realistic,
but what does it mean to set up
fortified enclaves of resistance
within a colonial space of war
that will fortify us
and lead to the possibility
of our liberation.
And so, to me, this
notion of (indistinct),
is one that we might be able to use
if we are to embrace the possibility
of putting these three terms
into conversation with one another
and I'll end it there, thank you.
- Ah, thank you so much,
Christen, there's so much...
I wanna move to Deb but I just
wanna name really quickly,
there's so much in what you said,
but I kept coming back to
something you said early on
about the terms that comfort us.
And then I started to think about the way
that terminology and
concepts without action
become sort of inebriate us.
The seduction and
inebriation of these terms
that don't have an action tied to it.
But then I was also
thinking about the ways
that language is a trap and confix.
And in some ways,
not totally capture what
is happening on the ground.
So I'm just gonna briefly...
And some of you have
heard this story about
how I came to anthropology
as an undergrad.
I was taking a course
that I did not know was
an anthropology course.
So it was an upper level
anthropology course
and we were reading these
beautiful ethnographies.
And to me,
what I recognized in what
was called anthropology,
but I didn't know it was called that yet,
until like the middle of the semester.
I realized what we were up to.
It was very much to me, a
Black feminist practice,
because the way that we were talking
about these ethnographies and
the practice of field work
was very much about how
you come into a community,
how you learn, how to be in community,
how you immerse and humble yourself,
what it means to take people's
experiences seriously,
to listen to stories and to be a witness
more than a documentarian.
And this is the way that I,
without the name of anthropology,
there was a way, so if we think about,
what is the there, there,
what could be retrieved?
I'm wondering if the terminology keeps us
from seeing what can be retrieved.
The labeling of the thing
keeps us from seeing
what is possible to, in
your terminology, Christen,
excavate from practices
that we're already doing
without having to fix it to a name.
So I just wanted to speak to some of that,
there's so much more in what you said,
but I'll just leave it there
because I wanna pass it on to Deb.
- Well, thank you very much, Aimee.
And I echo all of the thank yous
that Christen and Savannah
have already put forward.
Thank you for gathering us.
Thank you, Vanessa, for organizing us.
And I love being in dialogue with y'all
and have missed the sort of in person,
moments of huddle and hugs
and laughter,
and really good food
and conspiring together.
And I think that is something that,
we've really lost over the last two years.
And I think that's also
a big sense of strength,
for many of us going back
to our own institution.
So these moments when we get to
draw energy from that care
that we experience with each other.
So we do it online.
It's not quite the same,
but it is lovely to see your faces.
Aimee, where you sort of just intervened,
I think is where I might start,
which has to do with the
question of anthropology
and the extent to which
we situate ourselves
within a few called anthropology.
And you and I have had
this conversation before,
and I'm sure it's true of many of us here
in this space and beyond,
but I think like many folk I
sort of fell into anthropology.
I did not apply to PhD
programs in anthropology.
I had been dancing as Aimee
said, with Urban Bush Women.
And even before that,
had always been working through theater
or other kind of performative practices
as a way to enter community,
as a way to think together about
becoming conscious together
of the problems or issues within community
that we wanted to confront.
And then finding ways
through creative practices,
through the arts, through just
embodied pedagogy, I suppose,
to attend to some of those issues.
And that was my background as a performer.
And that's what sort of
drew me into the academy,
but not directly into anthropology.
And (indistinct) I had applied to
Latin American and
Caribbean studies program
and that's where I started.
And one of my first classes
was an anthropology class.
And I just remember recognizing,
again, like you, Aimee,
in the method of what we were reading,
that that was something
that I felt like I was already doing.
And that I didn't realize
that there was an name for.
And then when I took...
And that class was called
transnational processes.
So you can imagine,
with the person who would become
my advisor, Connie Sutton.
You can imagine it was a seminar,
it was a progressive take on globalization
and historicizing the inequalities
that were becoming exacerbated,
in late 80s through the 90s.
And when I then did the backtracking
to do the history of anthropology
and the theory of anthropology
is when I understood
what I was getting myself into.
And when I think, again, for many of us,
you consciously suspend disbelief
in order to get to the
thing that you think,
you know you're already doing.
So,
yes, I'm an anthropologist.
I love it for the things
that you're talking about
for the method of learning,
for the method of being in community,
for a mode of gathering
that can enact something in
the world that needs to happen.
But ultimately, I guess
the way I consider myself
is as someone who assembles archives,
archives, in my case, of violence
and of state violence in particular
and of struggles against state violence
and visions of a different world
in the face of state violence.
But these are archives
that could be stories.
They could be performative,
they could be sonic, they could be visual.
And the archive itself is not the end.
The archive is then a tool
in order to create something else.
And so I think that's the
basis of the scholarly work
that I do that ends up
in articles and in books,
but also the scholarly work that I do
that ends up in community
festivals or films
or performances,
or other kinds of institution building.
And not everything is for everybody.
Not every iteration of an
idea is for all audiences.
And so to me,
it's so important to think about audience
when thinking about the
work that we're doing,
what do I want this to do in the world?
And therefore, who is it for
and what form must it take
in order to do what it's supposed to do
for the people it is for?
So that takes on many
different kinds of things.
And I guess what...
It could have been anthropology,
it could have been many other things.
And I didn't go into this
to become a professor
that happened at the very last minute,
but there could have been
many other professional paths as well.
I do feel lucky to be in a
space where I have the time,
although it never feels like I have time,
but in theory I have the time
and absolutely have the
resources to distribute,
in other ways.
And I guess I see that
also as part of a mission,
which is to use the resources
of this very wealthy,
very large, very decentralized,
in many ways, amazing university
toward the furthering
of community projects
within Philadelphia and beyond.
So again, that looks like many things,
it looks like a Kumbla Festival
that a friend and I organize
every year in Jamaica,
or it looks like the conversation
that we're hoping to host
during the Kumbla Festival
about land dispossession,
in the particular community,
but also tying that to what's
going on and nationally
and transnationally,
or it looks like this article
that I'm really late on
about sovereignty that
I'm trying to put together
for a volume,
or it's a new film that we're working on
that really dissects the 70s in Jamaica
by looking at the Ethiopian
Zion Coptic Church
and the bizarre
intervention they made into,
socialist,
politics
and Rastafari,
race relations, I guess
I could put it that way.
And I think,
though I am situated in
an anthropology department
and have actually been editor
of an anthropology journal.
I am often not considered
an anthropologist
or I have heard or overheard,
I guess, people looking at my book,
my most recent book or
other work and saying,
"Oh, it's great, but is it anthropology?"
So I think that,
and I'm getting to the
abolition question in a minute,
but I think that,
while those of us who are
intentionally attempting
to transform the disciplinary
space that we're in,
are working through the
language of abolition
or of decolonizing
or liberation,
some of the other words
that have been used today.
I think it's also important
not to be too attached
to the label.
I think we would be fighting
those battles anywhere
and in any of the spaces that we occupy.
So, some of the work that
I think is super important
or that I spend a lot
of my time on right now
is also creating spaces
within this institution
that ultimately are about
undoing the institution.
And our center is a space like that.
The Center for Experimental Ethnography.
And we were very privileged to host Aimee
as one of our first fellows,
but that center is organized
to support faculty and students
who have a creative practice
as the basis of their research process.
And we have had filmmakers,
we have had dancers and choreographers,
we've had visual artists, textile artists,
we've had sound artists,
creative writers.
This semester we had Amitav Gosh
and we staged a musical
version of a parable
that he recently wrote.
And the point is to understand
artists as intellectuals
and creative work as intellectual work
and to therefore transform
the modes of knowledge production.
So in a way, it's trying
to bring the university
to what I understood
as knowledge production
before entering the university.
So in that way, it is about decolonizing.
And in that respect, I also would say that
all of these words that we use,
I tend to use them in the gerund form.
Even to think if we agree
that sovereignty is a
process and a practice,
and that liberation is a
then obviously decolonizing and abolishing
are also processes and practices
and they're not events,
they're not something that
happens and we can say,
Oh, we're done.
We've solved that problem,
it's an ongoing modality of life.
And I think that...
Oh, thank you for
putting that in the chat.
That guides me,
in everything I do.
So like in considering,
am I gonna give this talk
or am I gonna work on this project
or are we gonna co-sponsor this event?
Or whatever it is,
it's who is it serving?
Who is the audience?
How does it move through a process
and practice of decolonizing,
abolishing, liberating?
And how does it create joy in
our worlds and in our lives?
- Thank you so much.
I, as you were speaking, Deb,
was thinking about how much
of the work of abolition
is about remembering.
What I knew before I came to this,
what I was already doing,
what I had been doing and that,
through the training and the disciplining
of our minds and our bodies and...
Context, post all of that,
that maybe the first step in
abolition is a remembering,
a deep honoring of what we already know,
and we hold in our bodies
and in our spirits.
And I just wanna say,
for everybody listening,
I know you're listening intently,
there's some questions in
the chat that I wanna get to.
And what I've tried to do as you have been
giving your opening remarks
is just pepper in some
things that I wanna expand on
in between your remarks
and really, because what
you're saying is so rich
and so layered,
you've kind of hit on the other prompts
that I wanted to ask.
So I wanna make space for us
to be in genuine conversation
because people always say that,
like, "It's just a conversation
and then it's not."
And I think Christen said this,
was the first one to say it,
oh, I wanna ask you more
about this, to Savannah.
So I wanna open up space
before we move to the
questions in the chat
for you all to talk to one another,
if there's questions that
you have of one another
about your work, about
something that you said today,
I just wanna allow that space
for us to practice conv...
(indistinct) to practice conversation
(laughs) for us to be in conversation.
So I'll just open it up.
I don't know if there was something
that you wanted to start with, Christen.
- I was gonna say, I'm
like jumping into the line.
- Yeah, please.
- (laughs) A couple questions.
Exactly, Savannah.
I'm like jumping in.
I have two questions
and one is for Savannah
and one is for Deb.
I would really appreciate,
because part of what is
really inspiring to me
about your work, Savannah,
is just how much practice or praxis
is the center of your
work on abolition, right?
And so everything that you do
is in conversation with community
and in thinking about
those five understandings of abolition,
I just wanted to hear you
talk a little bit more
about how we create those
possibilities in community
and what does that it look like?
And for Deb, I am always
inspired by your research
and all of the amazing
community work that you do,
but I am also inspired by
the ways that you engage
in institution building and disruption,
which is one of the
things that you mentioned.
And one of the things that,
I think has been a key aspect of that
is your ability to bridge
community with the university.
And so, I wanted to hear
you talk a little bit more
about how we do that work,
because I think that that
is part of the process
of decolonizing or
liberating or abolishing,
whatever gerund we want to use.
I think at the heart of this
conversation is that process
of breaking down the university walls.
And I think that CCE
is a good example of...
Excuse me, CCE is a good example of that.
And I wanted to hear you talk
a little bit more about that.
- I love these questions,
look and before...
I know it's not my turn
to ask the question,
but I'm just gonna say it anyway,
when you said the hegemony shifting.
That is so, I mean...
I don't know if my trekkies are out there,
but it's like the Borg is adapting.
It's just thinking
about the ways in which,
"Oh, Charlie, see they
got me, they got me.
"I just said it, I just said
the ways in which they got me."
Thinking about how
malleable and how adapted,
how like fundamentally creative
death and captivity are.
And so I think there's that element.
And so I think these five
gears, this is just...
I mean, it's like five stars
in the night sky, right?
It's not a container.
They're just kind of points to look at.
And so I think part of our
job is not to fit into these,
but just to make more and more,
clear the clouds out the way
so we can see all of the ways
our community is getting free.
So that's one piece.
So I think, I am oriented
towards a proliferation
approach to abolition.
One in which, I think I said
something about this earlier,
somebody was saying something about,
oh, going towards abolition.
And so I think, certainly
in terms of a revolutionary
tradition of abolition or
one that's oriented around
the end of the prison industrial complex,
that's a very clear end goal.
And the prison industrial
complex is a giant black squid
of a leviathan.
So it's one thing to close
all the prisons in the world.
And so, similar I'll think
of it in terms of practice,
the Oakland School Police
Department is abolished.
And the day the last cop left schools,
are our children safe?
No.
One particular kind of vacuum of captivity
does not actually produce
the world that we need.
And to me, that's the distinction
between abolition and liberation.
I mean, I know Ruth Gilmore,
has the amazing conception of thinking
of abolition as growing things.
Again, these are different
ways of thinking about it.
They're all gonna work, but for me,
it's helpful to think about
abolition as that vacuum,
and that doesn't actually take
any of the responsibility away from us
to build a world worth living in.
And that that's not,
it's not only not an end goal,
it's also not anywhere near enough.
And so that's part of what
I'm concerned about too,
that all of a sudden the
floor has become the ceiling.
When the end of captivity
has become our dream of...
That's what we go to the altar for.
That's what we're pouring libation for
just to not be in captivity.
And so I don't think so,
but I think part of that
cohabitation of language
can also be a domestication
of political imaginaries.
And so for me, I'm really
invested in abolition
because I like destroying things.
(laughs) That's my gift.
I like breaking, I like ripping.
(stutters) We need a team.
So I guess for me,
nobody mistake my particular
interest in destruction
with a political program,
because that is not it.
It's gonna be way more, that's one thing.
And so then when you said,
how do we do this work.
Dr. Smith, who is "we?"
And I'm asking that because, I think-
- I was literally thinking about "we"
as in the small we in the room,
but I really take that point
'cause that's a good one.
'Cause that's part of what
happened in summer 2020.
- And it also happens...
I'll just say, as like boujee Black people
who have moved to another
place, paying a very high rent.
Not always, but often the
place that we don't live
or live in a different
neighborhood than we grew up in.
And so I think for me it's important
that who is "we" is not just about like,
race, class, gender.
But also about belonging and
different layers of indigeneity
and nativity is such that,
the folks who are directly impacted
are leading the work of whatever that is.
So when we're doing organizing
about working conditions in academia.
That's us right here.
We're doing that.
And when we're doing organizing around,
the hyper surveillance and
policing of welfare provision,
even if we may have been on WIC before,
if you're not on WIC right now,
you need to be in a listening role,
you need to be in a supporting
and amplifying role.
And so for me, that's why I
ask about who is the "we,"
'cause usually I'm not the "we,"
and it's my job to really
remind myself that, so.
- Yeah, that's such an
important point, Savannah.
And I think it's also,
where I might start to think
about Christen's question
about community and the university.
I mean, I think it's an
impossible relationship,
especially on a campus like
Penn and like many others
that has just continually expanded
to the detriment of the
surrounding community.
And there's constantly, and is,
this week, organizing around
building that's happening,
on one particular end of the campus.
So, we can understand
Penn as a growing space
that is dispossessing people
with a long history of
dispossessing people.
And honestly, even this
building that I'm in,
which is the anthropology department,
which is located in the Penn Museum,
which was built on
the former site of the
Philadelphia Blockley Almshouse.
Across the street is Franklin Field,
which was the potters
field for the Almshouse.
Again, dug up and...
in order to create the buildings
that are currently here
and in fact, for those of you
who know some of the recent
history of revelations
around what's going on in the Penn Museum,
I mean, some of the crania
that ended up in Morton's Collection
come from the Blockley Almshouse
and our Black Philadelphians.
So, these are the histories we
inhabit that I inhabit daily.
I walk into this building,
I am here with the people
living in the building
with the ancestors living in the building.
And on top of the people
whose graves were destroyed
in order to create the building.
So,
community building in
this university space
is impossible, really like
theoretically impossible.
That said,
again,
with the view toward
redistributing the resources
of the institution beyond its walls.
I mean, I think the arts is really a way
in which at least I know how to do that.
Other people know how to do
it through other mechanisms,
but since that is my background,
that is the tact that I take.
And it's always a negotiation
and an ongoing struggle of
recognizing the assumptions
that you have and the moments
when you think everybody's
on the same page.
And then you realize that you're not,
and oh, maybe we should have
had a conversation about this,
or I wouldn't have thought
to have a conversation about this,
or it's going on right now in a good way,
in a productive and generative way
with the collaboration that
Grace Sanders Johnson and I have
on a course that we're
team teaching right now
called "Citing Black Girlhood."
And one of our community partners
is the Colored Girls Museum in Germantown.
That's run by my very old
friend, Vashti DuBois.
And, there (indistinct)
have just been moments
when we have to regroup and say,
wait, what did you mean
when you said that?
Or how is this going to work
when we travel to Jamaica
or when we travel to South Africa,
how are the portraits going to go with us?
How are the other portraits
going to join that exhibit?
There are all of these things that,
we each may have particular ideas
about the logistics surrounding them,
but the logistics come out
of a theoretical and experiential miras.
So, they're all things to
be constantly negotiated.
So I think I would just echo Savannah
in talking about listening
and inhabiting the listening role,
yes, as Christen just wrote in the chat.
But I would also say that
I think all of these words,
abolishing, decolonizing, liberating
have temporalities also,
I think there are times
when we do the Weberian politics,
the hard, boring of hard boards.
And there are other times
when it is the moment to burn it down,
and we have to be able to recognize,
when is which time,
when to just say, you know
what, this isn't going to work.
We're not going to be able
to go forward in that way
and actually torch it,
and then move in a different
direction or regroup
come up from the ashes and think again
about what we want to build.
We can't beat our heads
against the same wall forever.
We have to build the new
wall and see if it holds.
- Mm, thank you so much for that.
All of you, I'm looking at the time.
And I think what I'd like to do
is go to some of the questions in the chat
and I'm gonna combine,
there's two questions that
were directly messaged to me,
and I think they're related.
So, is it cool with y'all if
I read both of the questions
and then we can see if you
can answer them together.
And I think you might have touched on
some of what is being
asked in the question.
So you could just maybe amplify
just a little bit of
what you've already said,
but the first one,
how does care, love and tenderness
come into y'all's respective work?
I'm thinking about Bell Hooks,
King's Beloved Community
and Cornel West's work.
Aimee, you started our conversation
expressing the care that
you have for our speakers.
I'm wondering what practices
you take in your daily lives
that cultivate spaces
or communities of care.
All right, so that's one question, right?
And I think, tell me
if I'm stretching here
to try to combine these.
How can we keep the sacredness and rituals
by the people we are working
with and learning from,
without having to adopt a
colonial supremacist method
of the, in quotes, "need to
know or need to explain,"
can something just be
sacred or unexplainable,
can part of our method be embedded
in the mystery, in our work?
And so, I throw those
two questions out for you
to answer them individually
or how you might see them connected.
- Maybe I'll start, (murmurs) okay?
Definitely opacity,
I think has to be a guiding principle
of anthropological work forward.
And there are many people
who have moved toward that
in different kinds of ways,
and ethnographies that are models.
I think of that kind of work,
I think Ana Lara's work,
Black freedom: Queer sovereignty,
Black sovereignty: Queer freedom
is one example of that kind of work.
And I think that is care work,
the respect for the right to not be known,
to not be parsed, to not
be described to death
and still in relation.
I think that that is
definitely part of a practice
of care within a research process.
I think also for me,
in terms of practices of
care in life generally,
or in the academic life,
has to do with gathering
and creating the conditions for gathering
in ways that can offer support and love
and really a view of the whole person
and to also acknowledge
one's own vulnerability
and need for support and love
and the need to be seen as a whole person.
And part of that is also about mentoring
and trying to make sure
there are more and more,
and exponentially more Black women
who are at the stage where
they're able to enact
their true vision.
I think Black women constitute...
Christina, actually Sharpe
told me this one time
when I was agonizing over
how many tenure letters
I had to write one year,
she told me that 2% of full
professors are Black women.
And that's why we get asked to write
for everybody in every discipline.
And I think, one can
see that and feel that
as a burden of course,
but if one sees it instead as
always enlarging the community
and in always being in a
condition of learning together
and embracing the work of others
in a fulsome way
then I think that too is
part of a practice of caring.
- Did Savannah or Christen,
do you wanna address
either of the questions
or there's another-
- Oh, go ahead.
There's (indistinct).
- We both said the same thing
at same, go ahead.
- Oh, no.
I (indistinct) mine is brief.
I mean, obviously
everything that Deb said,
and it's interesting that
you talked about the mystery
of our work, Aimee,
because I think for me,
one of the ways of
interrupting these kind of...
I'm not sure this is
exactly what you're asking,
but kind of this colonial
effect of extraction
in our workspaces is part
of what you're asking about,
like how do we not rehearse
that when we're in community?
I think rather than mystery,
one of the things that I've
really looked to is transparency
(indistinct) of the inverse.
So you might be a mystery
when it shows up on JSTOR.
But I think in the work of
having more transparency,
which I think initially
I thought was about like,
oh, sharing the writing,
see what you think about,
but actually really being
transparent about the labor.
Like what is the thing
that my job is like,
how do you get paid?
What do you need to get out of this
in order to keep your job,
like, be very clear about the CV
and the pace of productivity,
all this other kind of things
that I think are really
submerged in our work.
And we never talk about it in
the pieces that we're writing.
And we also rarely talk about
it with a community, right?
But then as opposed to being...
I think conversations,
I thought that initially
were about like, oh, do
you support this project?
So even when I was doing my dissertation,
the kinds of relationships
that I had with folks...
I knew some people already,
I had some relationships
'cause I worked at the
school for several years.
And when folks participated
in the research,
it wasn't because they were like,
we wanna contribute to
anthropological knowledge.
It was like, oh, Ms. Shange
is going back to school.
Ms. Shange wants to become a professor.
This is her dream, let's
help her everybody.
And people would be like,
this is so good, what you're doing, baby.
We love you, how can we help you, baby?
This is so wonderful.
And it wasn't because they were like,
you're gonna be a great
anthropologist of our community.
They were like, we see
that you want something.
And there's something
that I can share with you
that helps you get to where you wanna go.
And that was their gift to me.
So it wasn't that I was
kind of bringing back
some kind of gift to community.
It was really them saying,
you wanna do this cool thing,
you wanna be a professor,
we support you.
I gotta sign this thing and
tell you a story, I got that.
And so that for me, was
a gift from community.
And I think that kind of transparency
moving forward into the work
that I'm doing now to be like,
hey, I need to write an
article in the next two years.
It can really be about anything.
Like the space that
we're sharing right now.
So the project that I'm
working on right now
in terms of the political
work I was sharing before
talking with the folks,
and then being like,
Hmm, well, I really wanted
to work on writing too.
I'm actually a poet.
Is that something we could do together?
So now, we're in a very
kind of slow form process
of writing together,
what we're thinking of
as a collective history
of the process of producing
the George Floyd Resolution.
Which might at some point
show up in an academic journal
or some version of that.
But really it was because of being able
to have this conversation about my labor,
and then also being able to be like,
this does not have to
enter this space at all.
We don't have to do any of that.
And then I will go and write
another piece about another thing.
And so I think that transparency
has been a part of being able to hold care
in terms of the kind of
nuts and bolts labor aspect
of producing scholarship.
- Mm, I love that so much.
And Savannah does nothing
I've ever seen in any textbook
on activist research methods.
The transparency question is
never about what you just said.
which really would just change everything
in terms of the relationships
that would be developed.
And it's like, well, I reveal that,
how I'm gonna use the research on the IRB
and signing these forms of consent,
but to be really honest about the capital
that is gained for you as a researcher
in the work and what that means.
Thank you for that.
I'm wondering if, I'm looking...
I'm gonna wait for people
to add a little bit more to the chat.
There's one more question
that was privately sent to me,
but I think you've kind
of already answered it,
but I wanted to see, because
Christen asked a question
and I'm one wondering if Deb or Savannah,
you have a question for
your interlocutors here.
- Can I say something
about the healing thing,
really (indistinct) quickly.
- Sure, yes.
- I mean about the care,
because I wanted to add
this question of healing
because at least for me,
part of what I've really
tried to do in my work.
And when I say work, I mean
that really expansively,
not just in the research topic,
but also just kind of how
I engage with the academy
and how I engage
intellectually, et cetera,
is creating spaces of healing for people,
which is about community
building, et cetera.
But it's also about caring
for the sacred, right.
And caring for people's spiritual selves.
And so I wanted to put that out there
because I think that that's something
that also goes unsaid
and people don't
necessarily talk about that.
But I mean,
in a lot of ways,
what we do can come back
to giving people the space
and the time to heal
in ways they may not have been otherwise
because of the neoliberal
insistence on production.
And so, sometimes we
just create enough space
for somebody to just have a moment
where they're actually
thinking about themselves
and thinking about their lives
and thinking about what
they've been through
in a way that's protected and safe.
- Hmm.
Yes.
Savannah or Deb, do you have a question
for this collective, this trio?
If not, I can ask-
- I mean I have nothing but questions,
but I just like this piece about,
is it great but is it anthropology
is wild to hear from you as the person
who literally made me
into an anthropologist,
like out of thin air (laughs),
because I have no anthropology degrees
and now have this anthropology position,
I think because I was an
apprentice to you in this work,
I think in a really real
way and an old time version
of how it means to come into a profession,
but just kind of reflecting on this,
is it great but is anthropology.
I was also being asked by people
in great positions of
power in our discipline,
to get the job that I have right now.
What makes you one of us?
Like really like tests of faith,
this kind of test of
faith around anthropology,
it's just wild that it doesn't
stop to (indistinct) that.
- (indistinct) I'm not
(laughs), and I don't mean that.
- I did not say that is
how I got this position.
Pro's tip, if anyone
here gets that question,
answer ethnographically.
Works every time.
- Yeah, so I'm looking at the time
and I'm thinking that
we can move to closing.
So like, what do you wanna leave us with?
I also had a question about
teaching, but I'll save it,
but just what is...
There's so much to think with here.
I mean, we could go on for
two more hours at least,
but what is the thing you
want to leave us with,
or maybe it was that,
I love that idea of the burst of light.
And I think you put it
in the chat, Savannah,
that when we're thinking
about those five nodes
or those five tenets, really
the stars and the nice sky,
the burst of light,
and maybe there's
something that has come up
in this conversation today that is another
star in that constellation
that we wanna add to this dark night sky.
But yeah, can I start with you, Christen
to close this out with
what you would want us to
continue to think with?
- That's a great question.
You said a burst of light
and all I could think
about was Audre Lorde's,
"A Burst of Light,"
and really thinking about,
what Savannah was talking about
in terms of stars and constellations,
which to me, bursts of light and stars,
my brain goes together with those things.
And so, I mean, for me,
I think I would probably,
leave us with the thought that
in order for us to be able
to really get to a point
where our work is moving us
in a direction that feels
like it ensures life.
And it is freeing, right?
'Cause freedom is a word
we haven't really used yet,
but it's embedded in this question
of abolition and liberation.
I think that we have to keep
searching for new alternatives
and be comfortable with our discomfort.
I think that that to
me is really important.
Meaning we cannot get to the point
where we're so comfortable in where we are
that we neglect to remember
the need for constant struggle
and for vigilance.
And I think to me,
that is something that
I wanna leave us with.
- Thank you.
- Okay, vigilance, oh Deb, go ahead.
- Savannah, did you wanna go next?
- Yes, 'cause I think Deb
should have the last word.
- Stop.
- (indistinct), did it.
- Deb has incredibly mentored everyone
on this call.
- Everyone.
Where are the flower emojis?
Put the flower emojis in the chat
because Deb deserves the
flower now, not no roses.
I want blue orchids, bougainvillea,
okay, something with a little
flavor, a little movement.
But I think this is gonna sound...
I don't mean this in
(indistinct) like a...
What's that word grandiose way.
But you know that saying
that folks will ask
in certain kinds of community spaces,
what kind of ancestor do you wanna be?
And thinking about that
as a orientation to
political work to life,
certainly to like family
inheritance, right.
I think it's also applicable
within anthropology.
In terms of what is
the table we're setting
for the meal that we're not
ever gonna be able to eat.
And I think, Deb, I really
heard you speaking to this.
And again like you...
This may not be the time of the space,
but like the levels to which
you have really created,
infrastructure for life and survival
in a place that was not designed for us
and not for yourself.
Tunnels, pathways, bunkers.
You are like a real general in this war.
And in ways, (indistinct),
has always said specifically about you.
So I just wanna lift that up.
But like when folks are writing about...
Like, think about in 2016,
somebody's doing a
review of this and that,
like, what is the thing
that you want to be right
before your little parentheses
and not in terms of your theory.
But what is it terms of,
how are you positioning
yourself in this genealogy?
Are you offering something
that might be worth something to somebody?
And I think that's also true
in terms of our teaching,
in terms of our family legacies,
in terms of our political work.
Because I don't...
Maybe, listen, prove me wrong.
I don't think that I'm gonna live to see
what I think of as liberation.
And I also feel like I'm responsible
for offering something that
might be of use to the person
who is gonna be there at
that moment and at that day,
and it's not gonna be
something big, right.
It's gonna be something small.
But I think that for me is
how I orient towards this.
And similarly, you talked about teaching.
I would love to hear
your teaching question,
but in classes, I hope the
thing that the students get
is not the content, right?
Not the quotation in the book,
but something they can take with them
and put in their pocket and
fondle up between their fingers
on a really hard day.
- Yeah, that was-
- I'm sorry.
I was just tapping in the chat.
Yes, Savannah, that's totally
how I think about teaching.
And then I always feel
like I'm doing it wrong.
I'm like, this is about your spirit.
Anyway, Deb,
take us home.
- Yeah,
I was just gonna say that,
and this is on my mind
because graduate students
and a couple junior faculty
have raised this question recently,
they have a thing that
they're passionate about
that they think they should wait to do,
until the dissertation is done
or until I get tenure or until...
And I think what is important
is to do the thing one
is passionate about now
and figure out how to
work it into the thing
that's going to finish a dissertation
or get tenure or whatever,
because if we do not live
our lives, our dreams,
if we do not bring our whole selves,
but instead try to contort constantly
into whatever the figure is
that we imagine people want to see
from us in these spaces,
then the spaces themselves
will never change.
And one does one's own
mental health a disservice
to not pursue the important
question, the creative writing,
the activism, the organizing,
all of the above together, whatever it is.
So, I guess what I would say is
the true transformation can only come,
not only because we inhabit
these rarefied spaces,
but because we inhabit them as
the total people that we are
with the desires that we have,
and that we bring everybody with us
into those spaces as well.
- Oh, thank...
I was writing in the chat.
So my teaching question was,
you all already answered it.
I was just wondering
how we've talked about,
terminology and how we think about
and across institutional
spaces, but what does it mean,
not just in our own research,
but in the classroom,
how do we teach, are we
doing that when we teach?
And I don't know who said that about,
it's not about the quote,
it's the (laughs)...
What can you take with you
to move through these streets?
Ugh, anyway.
I just wanna say before we log off
that we have speaking of teaching
and speaking of the next
generation and mentorship
that we have with us in our company,
some of the newly
admitted graduate students
in African American Studies.
And so, they're here
listening to this conversation
so glad to have you all here,
so glad you could make it.
I have nothing but the deepest adoration
for all three of you.
And the work that you do
has liberated my ability
to be in the academy.
And I mean that sincerely.
From the first time I met you, Deb,
I realized that it was possible
to be in the academy...
What is it to be in it, but not of it.
To be in it, but not of it, right.
And to find that way, I think
June Jordan talks about this,
that you're moving through spaces,
like an eel almost, without
getting anything on you,
but as you're moving through spaces,
you're creating those tunnels
that Savannah was talking about
for others to come through behind you.
So maybe they don't have
to be so slippery (laughs).
Maybe they can be upright
as they move through those tunnels.
So anyway, I just wanna thank
everyone for coming out.
I am rem...
Please forgive me, we have
another Endeavors Session,
I believe on the 20...
Let me look at my...
We'll send you all the notification,
but we'll be discussing
Eli Anderson's latest book,
which will be very exciting.
It'll be myself, Eli
Anderson and Gerald Jaynes.
So I hope you all can make that.
And I'm gonna look on...
I believe it's the 21st,
but you'll get a notification around that.
But I just wanna thank
you so much, Christen,
Savannah and Deb,
and for all of your wonderful questions,
this was just like, just the bomb
that we all need in these times.
And today, I mean that this week,
like I needed this so desperately.
Take good care of yourselves.
I'll be speaking to you soon, I'm sure.
Thank you all for coming out
and see you soon and next time.